on va à présent ouvrir une page spéciale
consacrée à Simone Veil il y a Simone le
voyage du siècle sort en salle
aujourd'hui c'est un film important qui
montre combien tous les combats de
Simone Weiss sont plus que jamais
d'actualité la comédienne Elsa
Zilberstein qui incarne Simone Veil à
l'écran il est exceptionnel vous allez
le voir elle nous rejoint dans un
instant avec le réalisateur Olivier
Dahan mais aussi avec Jean-Louis Debré
et Aurore berger on les accueille tous
ensemble juste après l'invitation signée
ce soir elles amont d'agara
si on vous invite Elsa Zilberstein et
Olivier Dahan c'est parce que vous avez
décidé de raconter une figure du 20e
siècle une histoire française un destin
hors du commun pour vous Simone Veil
méritait un grand film alors Elsa
Zilberstein pour incarner cette icône
vous avez travaillé sa voix ici à
l'Assemblée nationale la voix de Simone
Weil c'est celle qui a défendu le droit
l'avortement la parole est à Madame le
Ministre de la Santé je voudrais tout
d'abord vous faire partager une
conviction de femmes je m'excuse de le
faire devant cette assemblée presque
exclusivement composée d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes nous voulons mettre fin à
l'avortement clandestin une voix de
femme façade des hommes parfois très
hostiles certains n'hésitant pas à
comparer l'avortement au chambres à gaz
barbarie organisée comme elle le fut
hélas il y a 30 ans par le nazisme en
Allemagne que peut-il y avoir à ce
moment-là dans la tête de celle qui a
survécu à l'horreur des camps de
concentration
publiquement elle n'a alors jamais
évoqué son passé elle le fait lors de
l'inauguration d'un hôpital presque
malgré elle
[Musique]
la France apprend que Simone Veil est
une rescapée un passé que la femme
politique évoque avec force en 1979
quand le Front national perturbe un de
ses meetings
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui très survécu la pire que vous avez
fait de mettre le bordel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Simone Veil consacrera sa vie à
témoigner témoigner pour ne jamais
oublier l'horreur de la Shoah
bonsoir Elsa liberstein et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici à l'Assemblée nationale
là où d'ailleurs vous avez tous les deux
tourner une partie du film dans
l'hémicycle du Palais Bourbon et là où
Simone Veil est entré dans l'histoire
bonsoir Olivier Dahan merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour ce
beau film dont vous êtes le réalisateur
on va revenir avec vous sur le débat sur
l'IVG de 1974 75 qui a été d'une
violence inouïe dans l'hémicycle et la
manière dont vous le mettez en scène
bonsoir Jean-Louis Debré vous êtes un
peu chez vous ici on est ravi de vous
retrouver ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale merci d'avoir
accepté d'évoquer Simone Veil que vous
avez rencontré tout jeune vous allez
nous raconter d'ailleurs vous en parler
Simone Veil est une des femmes qui ont
réveillé la France dans votre livre chez
Faya et d'ailleurs dans votre spectacle
qui je crois cartonne dans les Sun les
meilleures scènes de France c'est j'ose
dire enfin bonsoir robergé présidente du
groupe Renaissance il y a des députés à
l'assemblé pour qui Simone Veil est un
modèle qui mène la source de
l'engagement en politique et je crois
que c'est votre cas on va en parler avec
vous et vous avez d'une certaine façon
envie de continuer son combat avec une
proposition de loi Elsa et le Bersheim
c'est un projet que vous portez depuis
des années vous êtes à l'initiative de
ce film pourquoi c'était si fondamental
et presque envie de dire si viscéral
pour vous d'incarner Simone Veil au
cinéma déjà parfois des fois on
n'explique pas toujours les choses de
manière concrète et précise je crois que
c'est la rencontre avec elle qui m'a
transformer
ému et
chamboulé vraiment j'ai eu la chance de
la rencontrer plusieurs fois et au fil
de nos rencontres je me suis dit assez
vite il faut un grand film sur cette
femme peut-être parce que ce modèle de
résilience de puissance
[Musique]
d'incandescence de vibrants de
vibrations et ce modèle de survie
me fascinait et je me suis dit elle est
la France elle est elle est la France en
fait elle représente un tel modèle de
courage
qu'elle était après je me suis plongée
dans une vie et je me suis dit mon dieu
c'est c'est la petite histoire dans la
grande histoire elle parle d'elle qui
vient de l'horreur qui vient de l'enfer
de de l'ignoble pour aller vers la
lumière et pour et pour transformer
finalement
ça survie et transformer tout ce qu'elle
a vécu en fait je disais que c'était un
film important parce que il va sortir
quasiment au moment où les derniers
survivants la Shoah s'éteigne et elle
dit vous vous dites
j’étais et plus personne ne pourra dire
j'y étais et plus personne ne pourra
dire voilà ce qui fut c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il fallait le faire pour
transmettre cette mémoire oui c'est un
film aussi se faire sur la mémoire
d'ailleurs
sur notre passé notre avenir comment on
transforme le passé comment qu'est-ce
qu'on apprend du passé ou pas c'est
c'est au travers elle qu'on parle du
siècle donc je crois que c'était aussi
peut-être par rapport à ma famille
inconsciemment j'avais envie de oui mais
pas que en fait c'est je pense c'est
assez impalpable pourquoi on a envie en
tout cas je pensais que c'était une
femme hors du commun peut-être pour la
transmission quand même et pour tous ces
combats et de me dire c'est une femme
hors du commun qui s'est battue aussi
pour la dignité des êtres contre les
injustices et sa manière la manière
qu'elle a eu de se battre sans être une
femme politique pure accrocher à son
petit pouvoir mais une femme hors norme
qui s'est toujours battue pour les
autres et pour le respect des droits de
l'homme et ça c'est une dimension assez
importante je vous dirais d'ailleurs
comment on se prépare un rôle pareil
puisque c'est pas si c'est évident
Olivier Dahan il y a un peu un fil rouge
quand même dans le film c'est que cette
parole des survivants au fond elle hante
Simone Veil systématiquement cette
histoire lui est ramené est-ce que c'est
aussi parce que après guerre la parole
n'était pas possible elle était tabou il
voulait parler les survivants et on les
a signé au silence et on voit ça dans le
film pratiquement tout du long j'ai
voulu montrer ça effectivement dans le
film quelque chose qu'on voit un peu
souvent en fait qui était la chape de
plomb qui s'est abattue sur les sur les
ceux qui sont revenus et qui étaient en
gros ne pas parler en fait tout
simplement parce que l'État était avancé
et pas revenir même sur le passé très
très récent et donc pas une interdiction
mais la société a fait que on avait pas
le droit de parler non effectivement on
n'a pas le droit les Français ne
pouvaient pas entendre en tout cas pas
tout de suite et donc les gens se sont
conformés à ça en fait plus ou moins en
fait alors c'est un film qui est un peu
mosaïque c'est pas du tout un biopic
classique puisque c'est à la faveur de
l'écriture de ces mémoires que Simone
Veil revit des moments des flashbacks
fondateurs de sa vie on est à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est impossible
de pas évoquer c'est une salinaugurale
tout de suite on est
1974 début 75 et puis à ce débat alors
là racontez-nous parce que c'est d'une
violence mais d'une violence inouïe
d'une certaine façon les camps la
rattrape à ce moment-là dans l'émission
j'ai juste pris tous les relevés
officiels et il n'y avait que malgré
tout à apprendre c'est quasiment
verbatif toutes les attaques bien sûr il
y a le texte que fait que dit Elsa en
Simone Veil qui dit le texte
effectivement
on a que les archives de Simone Veil on
n'a pas le contre le papa les débats
filmés des députés comme
quand je me documentais beaucoup pour
écrire ben j'ai lu effectivement c'était
hallucinant c'était d'une violence
extrême c'était tous les cousons de
permis et c'était c'était comment dire
par exemple de la poste c'est pas bon on
la compare à un médecin nazi dans
l'hémicycle avec cette loi il y a une
phrase qui est lancée si les embryons
sont à vos yeux désagrégresseurs et bien
ses agresseurs vous accepterez madame
qu'il soit jeté au four crématoire voilà
Aurore berger ce qu'on disait il y a
quoi une cinquantaine d'années c'est
qu'est-ce que je raconte non il y a 20
oui 40 oui une cinquantaine d'années un
peu moins de 50 ans j'ai eu la chance de
voir le film et j'étais très frappé à la
fois par la pudeur avec laquelle son
histoire est racontée et aussi à quel
point on la redécouvre parce qu'en fait
on a tous une image un peu de Simone
Veil on a tous un morceau de sa vie qui
nous touche ou qui nous parle plus
singulièrement que notre et revoir son
parcours de magistrate par exemple ma
particulièrement frappée et à quel point
ça fait écho aussi par rapport à ce
qu'on vit ce qui est certain c'est que
on parle beaucoup depuis cet été des
débats qui sont des débats agités qui
peuvent être violents à l'Assemblée
nationale quand on est au cœur de
l'hémicycle on ressent cette emprise
physique c'est sans commune mesure avec
ce qu'elle a subi avec ce qu'elle a
travaillé
à transformer parce qu'en fait c'est ça
qui est frappé neuf femmes à l'Assemblée
contre 480 hommes et c'est vrai que la
violence qu'on a regardé avec Olivier ce
qu'on lui a dit on l'a réduite à son
rang de femme et de déporter et on lui
en a foutu plein la gueule et la force
avec laquelle elle s'est relevée et
qu'elle a vaincu grâce d'ailleurs à
Antoine veuille qui a été merveilleux et
qu'il l'a aidé avec l'audius petit et la
Ferrand il a renversé
le travail qu'Antoine veuille a fait
aussi par derrière c'était assez
hallucinant mais c'est vrai que c'est
étonnant de voir la violence je sais pas
comment c'est aujourd'hui on connaît
tous cette photo où elle a ses mains
plongée
et en fait pas du tout elle est juste
fatiguée il faut pas trop généraliser
car il faut jamais oublier que la loi a
été votée par 200 quatre voix contre 189
après des débats d'une violence mais on
était habitué à Assemblée nationale et à
la Chambre des députés avant à ses
débats et violence reprenait tous les
débats donc ce qui est très important
c'est qu'il y a pas une Simone Veil il y
a plusieurs Simone Veil il y a d'abord
cette femme qui avait courage avec
détermination avec dignité à incarner la
déportation des Juifs de France à un
moment où on en parlait pas oui il
fallait pas parler ou c'était tabou
et là elle a mené un combat pour
l'histoire et pour l'avenir combat pour
l'histoire pour qu'on oublie pas ce qui
s'est passé mais pour que l'avenir
n'oublie pas cette histoire vous-même
vous l'avez rencontré très très jeune
vous connaissiez la famille d'Antoine
les poux dessus
et puis je me suis première fois que
j'ai rencontré je devais avoir 14-15 ans
elle m'a dit qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
et je dis je veux devenir magistrat
parce que je suis venu et mais c'est
très bien moi aussi je suis magistrat et
c'est le premier mot que j'ai entendu et
après ce qui serait frappant dans cette
femme quand on regarde notre histoire il
y a très peu de personnages qui émergent
30 ans ou 40 ans après ils sont partent
dans l'oubli du temps sauf une femme qui
est la deuxième femme en France ça va
être ministre à temps plein à plein
exercice après Madeleine chapeau point
pinceau s'appuie sur la quatrième avant
on avait des secrétaire d'État c'est la
première fois et cette femme qu'on
connaît uniquement parce qu'elle a
incarné cette déportation tout d'un coup
elle va forcer l'admiration de ses
adversaires et de ses amis je reprends
la phrase parce que avec courage sans
ultrances
avec
ma 113 humaine elle a fait passer cette
loi à l'Assemblée puis au Sénat et puis
un troisième personnage parce que cette
femme qui a vécu la guerre comme
personne ne peut l'avoir vécu sauf des
familles elle va en tant que présidente
du Parlement européen
vrai pour la réconciliation entre les
Allemands et les Français
la femme en fait elle est féministe elle
est féministe sans avoir été MLF sans
forcément être de gauche il y a un
personnage très important dans le film
c'est la mère de de Simone Yvonne
à qui elle doit tout en fait elle doit
se cette volonté farouche de s'émanciper
de travailler d'être indépendante elle
lui fait découvrir Louise Weiss et ça
s'est formidable pour tous ceux qui
connaissent pas qui vont découvrir
c'était qui cette Simone qu'on voit ici
sa mère une femme extrêmement importante
pour elle elle a toujours l'impression
que sa mère est plutôt les rendre plus
douce plus compréhensive qu'elle et
d'ailleurs Marceline Loridan et parle
beaucoup de la mère de Simone quand
elles sont à birkana elle dit qu'elle
était tellement rassembleuse généreuse
merveilleuse Simone avait toujours
l'impression que sa mère était mieux
qu'elle et quand elle perd sa mère dans
les camps voilà c'est sa blessure elle
ne s'en remet jamais non seulement la
blessure des camps comme elle disent les
filles les filles de birkana au restent
à birkana elles sont comme mortes une
partie d'elle qui est morte mais cette
mère qui lui a transmis le goût de
l'effort du travail lui disant moi j'ai
pas pu faire ce que je voulais j'ai pas
pu faire mes études enfin devenir
chimiste ou biologiste donc toi il
faudra que tu te battes et que tu te
travailles pour être indépendantes et
elle lui a transmis ça très jeune alors
que c'est c'était une époque où les
femmes travaillaient pas donc c'était
vraiment d'une modernité hallucinante et
c'est vrai que cette mère est fondatrice
et et
à 97 ans ça secrétaire me disait qu'elle
toujours de moments à 87 ans encore
ouais il y a une scène très forte
d'ailleurs qui qui raconte comment la
première fois elle parle des camps dans
une interview rester célèbre et elle dit
au fond je vais peut-être plus dur que
ma mère et ma sœur qui n'ont pas pu
résisté il y a une intégrité morale très
très forte aussi de Simone Veil
illustrations quand elle est ministre de
la Santé confrontée au premier malade du
sida regardez
donc comment ça va se passer alors je
vous explique la rédaction du journal
veut commencer le 20H directement sur
l'image de cette porte vous serez déjà à
l'intérieur prétendument en train de
parler à un malade du sida on vous
donnera un signal vous sortirez et vous
pourrez donner votre discours en direct
et après on lancera les titres et
je comprends pas bien en fait donc vous
êtes en train de me dire qu'il n'y aura
pas de malade dans la chambre non
avec vous dans la chambre c'est
symbolique en quelque sorte
j'ai besoin de vérité je veux pouvoir
parler avec un vrai malade dans une
vraie chambre au moins pendant 20
minutes avant mon intervention et être
en tête avec lui est-ce que c'est clair
on ne mentira pas
vide on pensait que pour votre confort
il était préférable mais je m'en fiche
de mon confort monsieur
je préfère être dans l'inconfort que
dans le mensonge est-ce que c'est clair
on va trouver une solution attendez je
vous en prie
voilà il y a tous ces mauvaises dans
cette scène je préfère la confort que
d'être dans le mensonge elle peut être
dure aussi elle était je pense qu'il
fallait qu'elle soit dur je pense qu'il
faut être dur je pense en réalité quand
on s'oppose comme ça d'une manière enfin
comment dire en tant que femme en tant
que politique aussi il y a un moment
donné pour faire passer ses idées
j'imagine qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
être dur et en même temps elle était
quand même nourri d'une grande grande
humanité également mais simplement la
carapace c'était je pense très épaisse
effectivement Jean-Louis Debré c'est
vrai que souvent on entendait les
politiques oh là là Simone Veil
comme grand allié Jacques Chirac qui lui
a mis
et en même temps ils ont pas toujours
été alliés en politique vous savez on
n'est jamais très longtemps amis ou très
longtemps adversaire mais c'est pas ça
mais le souvenir que j'ai dans ma dans
ma tête de Simone Veil
c'est une femme
extrêmement digne et on a le sentiment
qu'elle porte en elle une souffrance
qui ne peut pas s'effacer et elle ne
peut pas s'effacer et dans son action
contre le sida dans son action contre
les conditions d'hébergement des détenus
il y a un mot qui revient
ce sont des êtres humains et elle qui a
vu la mort vu la mort de sa famille qui
a vu le noir arriver
il y a un espèce de sursaut même si ils
sont pas bien ce sont des êtres humains
qui ont le droit au regard et à une
certaine compassion elle faisait pas de
la politique pour pour elle-même ça
c'est une ce que je disais en fait ce
qui est troublant et magnifique et fou
c'est justement comment se départ de vie
à conditionner tous ces choix ensuite et
ensuite et cette bataille pour la
dignité en disant ce sont des êtres
humains on peut pas laisser les gens
comme ça quel dans leur faute quel que
soit en prison ce que les gens ont fait
je me battrai jusqu'au bout quand elle
va en Yougoslavie et qu'elle parle pour
la Yougoslavie et qu'elle dit qu'est-ce
qui se passe que fait la Croix-Rouge en
fait il y a une bataille profonde
quelqu'un me racontait une anecdote je
crois que c'était 12,tublique en général
il me raconte on lui raconte ce qui se
passe à Sarajevo elle dit je pars tout
de suite ils ont pris un avion le soir
même ils sont allés donc c'est quelqu'un
qui s'indigne et ça c'est un dignation
elle est essentielle et avec audace et
sans peur elle va pour en tout cas
regarder les gens avec une empathie et
une et un regard qui lui est propre je
trouve
même si ça va à l'encontre d'une idée
admise parce que quand elle va s'en
souvient s'élever contre la condition
des détenus en qu'est-ce qu'on dit
également on les prisons ces trois
étoiles non attention ce sont des êtres
humains et peut-être demain a le droit à
être regardé être entendu quel que soit
les fautes qu'il a commises
cette passion
l'être humain la capacité à s'indigner
on parle beaucoup d'indignation
aujourd'hui dans notre époque est-ce que
c'est la même je pense qu'on a peut-être
une indignation qui est parfois plus
facile que les combats qu'elle a pu
mener parce que l'indignation n'était
pas facile quand il s'agissait de
dénoncer les conditions carcérales à
l'époque quand il s'agissait de monter à
la tribune pour justement les droits
humains avec ce fil rouge tendu en
permanence sur la question de la dignité
humaine quand on parle aujourd'hui de la
question des droits des femmes vous
voyez bien que malheureusement parfois
on en parle pas justement sous ce prisme
là de la capacité à se dire qu'en fait
c'est un continuum sur la manière avec
laquelle les droits humains doivent être
appréhendés dans une société et je pense
que elle elle avait cette force là de
Constance en fait il y a un moment il y
a rien qui se casse dans son parcours
tout est lié tout est cohérent tout est
constant et donc à un moment c'est aussi
ça dans les reconnaît d'intransigeance
mais c'est aussi un transgengeance
morale qu'elle avait évidemment mais du
coup que chacun lui reconnaît y compris
ce qu'ils l'ont ardemment combattu
personne ne pouvait nier l'intégrité qui
était la sienne et encore une fois le
combat qu'il animait viscéralement pour
reprendre alors on va parler de
l'actualité de ses combats est-ce que
c'est vrai quand on les met bout à bout
c'est fou en fait elle avait tout
compris c'est à dire que le féminisme
elle y était de plein pied lentilles
totalitarisme
l'antifascisme la lutte pour les valeurs
pour la démocratie et l'Europe on y
vient le féministe c'est l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes c'est pas un
être unique qui est l'homme était-il la
femme non elle considérait que les êtres
humains regardez
mes chers collègues mesdames messieurs
c'est un très grand honneur que vous
m'avez fait en appelant à la présidence
du Parlement européen
[Musique]
aussi
l'émotion qui est la mienne en prenant
place à ce fauteuil
est-elle plus profonde que je ne serai
l'exprimer
j'ai exprimé la gratitude que nous
devons avoir à l'égard de Louise Weiss
qui a si bien guidé nos premiers pas
vous me permettrez d'y revenir d'un mot
sans vous formaliser que je cite la
paraéminente qu'à la prise dans toutes
les luttes menées pour l'émancipation
des femmes
est une grande espérance parce qu'elle
est le bastion de la démocratie et de la
liberté
comment ne pas être conscient de la
nécessité de nous unir pour nos épaules
et les uns les autres
et résister ainsi à tout retour du
totalitarisme
et la liberté
de ses combats aujourd'hui ce qu'on
disait souvent un olivier c'est que
discours ouais malheureusement tout est
discours ils auraient pu être écrit il y
a deux mois afin c'est impressionnant
l'écho actuel entre l'avortement
l'Europe le totalitarisme que vous
disiez c'est fou comme le film n'est
plus un film qui parle d'une époque le
film parle de nous aujourd'hui et ça
c'est assez fou il y a comme comme si
c'était un écho
à incarner un rôle pareil avec le souci
aussi de dire des choses sur aujourd'hui
ça c'est Olivier qui écrit le scénario
donc moi en l'occurrence
comment on y arrive on se prépare
comment le préparation ah ça c'est
encore autre chose c'est un long chemin
la préparation c'est un an de
préparation qui doit partir des pieds
pour arriver dans mon corps pour que
j'arrive à l'incarner
ne plus imiter en tout cas à la voir
comme une seconde nature comme une
seconde peau essayez de que chaque jette
chaque vibration chaque regard j'ai
tellement regardé de documentaires de
documents sur l'inna Media Pro tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps je
parlais comme elle je marchais comme
elle après intégrer des mouvements et
des choses qui je voulais disparaître
enfin en étant là forcément quand tu es
actrice ou juste d'être là à 1000% pour
l'interpréter mais moi m'effacer devant
elle et la faire arriver en moi je peux
pas dire parce que c'est facile de
quitter un rôle pareil
non mais je cherche pas à le quitter en
fait j'ai elle vous accompagne il y a
des parties d'elle qui sont encore là et
puis ça part quand ça part et puis elle
m'a beaucoup donné aussi dans sa
puissance je voudrais qu'on revienne sur
ce qui se passe justement
le fond de l'air de l'époque quand on
voit aujourd'hui que les figés de Simone
Veil est taguée de croix gammée pas
seulement son portrait mais quand on
voit des étoiles jaunes revenir Aurore
berger dans les cortèges contre le pas
sanitaire ou même dans le mouvement des
gilets jaunes il y a eu aussi cette
polémique plutôt maladroite
dans le Val-d'Oise ou un parc un parc
Simone Veil a été regardé
décorer si j'ose dire et du plus mauvais
effet le panneau a été a été retiré
qu'est-ce qui se passe Aurore berger
est-ce que est-ce que ce passé qui ne
passe pas est encore là omniprésent
je crois que malheureusement il y a des
combats qui sont un peu intemporel je
pense qu'on tour de ce plateau on serait
tous heureux et satisfait de se dire que
le combat contre l'antisémitisme est un
combat qui est derrière nous comme un
certain nombre d'autres combats
évidemment je crains que malheureusement
ce ne soit pas le cas et qui faille
avoir la lucidité de le regarder en face
et de se dire que il revient que malgré
tout il revient peut-être il entretient
que certains l'entretiennent un peu tout
le monde entretien parce que c'est
quelquefois une façon de faire une sorte
de variable d'ajustement même politique
quelquefois je trouve je trouve qu'on on
se sert trop de ce sujet là aussi en
politique aussi pour pour servir
d'autres buts en fait donc et ça quelle
que soit en réalité les parties
j'entends trop souvent personnellement
parler d'antisémitisme des choses comme
ça de sur les chaînes d'infos ou sur non
pas pour le combattre mais pour s'en
servir justement pour se positionner
pour
pour se donner une posture quelquefois
pour le pour le pire je voudrais vous
montrer une mosaïque de dirigeants
politiques de pays dans lesquels le
droit à l'avortement est remis en cause
à différents degrés les États-Unis avec
Donald Trump puisque il est à l'origine
de la nomination des juges de la Cour
suprême qui ont interdit ou la
possibilité d'interdire à différents
états le recours à l'avortement Georgia
Meloni qui vous restreinte son accès ou
en tout cas certains de ces
parlementaires en Italie je pense aussi
à Chypre il y a de Polonais aussi
morachevski ou encore Victor urban en
Russie et bien sûr il jaillir bolsonaro
est-ce qu'il est menacé ce droit dans
notre pays Aurore berger est-ce que
c'est pour ça que vous voulez le
sanctuariser je pense qu'il faut pas
considérer que c'est un acquis
inébranlable parce que ceux qui ont
considéré que c'était le cas notamment
aux États-Unis se sont réveillés en
voyant qu'en fait il y avait eu un
travail extrêmement patient extrêmement
organisé des mouvements conservateurs
qui confondu la Cour suprême à prendre
une décision d'une brutalité sans nom
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois
on a dans ce qui est supposé être la
plus grande démocratie au monde les
États-Unis des femmes qui ne peuvent
plus avoir accès à l'avortement sauf à
prendre le risque d'année de prison des
médecins qui ne peuvent plus pratiquer
librement donc je crois que aujourd'hui
moi j'ai l'honneur d'être parlementaire
et quand on a cette responsabilité et
qu'on sait qu'on a la possibilité à un
moment de sanctuariser ce droit en
l'inscrivant dans notre Constitution je
pense qu'on a pas le droit de ne pas le
faire parce que sinon peut-être que ça
n'arrivera jamais et tant mieux si ça
n'arrive jamais mais en quelques années
quelques mots sur des avortements de des
avortements de convenance elle est
revenue sur ses parents quand on dit
qu'on va des rembourser enfin on peut ne
pas vouloir pour ne pas inquiéter
délibérément ou pour se donner une image
plus respectable essayer de trouver des
chemins de traverse pour ne pas dire que
frontalement
et puis derrière on voit des incises
progressifs qui sont faites qui
confortent ceux qui clairement veulent
en finir avec l'IVG et on a pour la
première fois aujourd'hui au sein de
notre émission au sein de la
sonnationale des députés rassemblance
nationale qui ont été élus et qui disent
ce qui était dit à l'époque qui disent
que l'IVG est un génocide de masques qui
parle de Shoah donc il faut avoir ça en
tête et je pense que ça c'est notre
responsabilité de le combattre et donc
de l'inscrire dans la Constitution
puisque nous on en a l'opportunité j'ai
envie Debré
à toucher à constitution ça devient
illisible il y a une déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui
prévoit l'égalité la dignité et la
Constitution c'est pour l'organisation
des pouvoirs publics alors si on en
revient de ces vieilles traditions où on
met tout pourquoi pas mettre
l'antiraptisme antisémitisme et tout ce
que je veux dire c'est que
soyons forts
le la lutte contre l'avortement
le racisme la xénophobie
soir de France histoire des hommes les
uns contre les autres ce sont des
moments de de de
fièvre où on lui on voit des phénomènes
de racisme de xénophobie d'antisémitisme
la réponse est une réponse collective
c'est que on apprenne dans les classes
dans les écoles ce que c'est que la
liberté ce que c'est que la dignité de
l'homme et que la télévision
essaye de montrer c'est parce que quel
est l'enseignement de Simone Veil c'est
une femme qui connaissait parfaitement
la conjoncture politique économique et
sociale et qui disait mon combat est un
combat pour l'histoire pour qu'on
n'oublie pas mais c'est pas c'est un
combat pour l'histoire pour préparer
l'avenir alors si on commence parce que
c'est trop facile les politiques on l'a
mis dans la Constitution à
débrouillez-vous mais c'est pas ça
il y a un certain nombre de valeurs qui
sont des valeurs de respect de la
personne humaine de respect de la femme
et que l'avortement fait partie
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
fait partie
Aurore berger j'ai vu voilà que vous
n'en reveniez pas
je savais pas donc par rapport à ce que
vous dites quelque part je comprends
qu'elle me qu'elle dise il faut que ce
soit inscrit dans la constitution même
si comment regarder
la Constitution ça fixe l'organisation
il y a la déclaration le préambule et
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics la
Constitution c'est l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics
dans l'hémicycle puisque Aurore berger
va déposer cette proposition de loi
[Musique]
discuter de ça il y a longtemps c'est
fascinant de voir que c'est un éternel
recommencement elle pensait de notre
époque je me permets jamais de penser de
dire ce qu'elle aurait pu penser je
parle pas pour elle après je peux dire
qu'elle manque qu'une figure comme ça
justement qui est pas accroché à son
poste politique ou à ses ambitions
personnelles oui ces indignations
manquent sa présence manque tout ce que
je peux dire c'est sûr merci beaucoup
merci infiniment d'avoir participé à ce
débat Simone la traversée d'un siècle
c'est le voyage pardonnez-moi le voyage
du siècle je voudrais signaler le livre
qui a été coordonné par le
documentariste écrivain David Teboul qui
est merveilleux Simone et ses sœurs je
suis sûr que vous le connaissez
Madeleine d'ailleurs Milou et dans le
film peut-être un mot sur elle parce que
c'est aussi elle perd sa sœur en 1952
alors qu'elle vit à Stuttgart elle est
repartie vivre en Allemagne avec Antoine
veille et sa soeur vient la visiter et
elle repart à un accident de voiture
c'est une deuxième un deuxième drame
enfin elle a traversé
un autre enfant voilà après et un
dernier mot peut-être sur Antoine veille
parce qu'Antoine veille au départ
c'était lui qui devait être dans la
lumière c'est lui qui devait faire de la
politique Aurore Bergé Antoine veille il
était moderne il a essayé mais devant le
charisme devant ce courage de sa femme
il a su bien avant l'heure se mettre en
retrait
je sais pas si c'est mis en retrait
c'est à dire qu'à un moment il a fait un
choix en conscience qui était de lui
permettre à elle de réaliser ce que
peut-être lui-même n'aurait pas pu
réaliser mais elle-même n'aurait pas pu
être Simone Veil Antoine c'est Antoine
d'ailleurs c'est la demande qu'elle a
formulé et qui a été respectée au moment
de son décès c'est qu'il ne soit jamais
séparés absolument au Panthéon immortel
merci merci beaucoup vous avez compris
LCP vous recommande très très
chaleureusement d'aller voir Simone le
voyage du SEC merci beaucoup elry
Berstein merci Olivier Dahan Aurore
berger Jean-Louis daubrais très belle
soirée sur LCP à demain
[Musique]